and I like to say I that's what I did I
followed War Herzog so blame
him I'm wondering what you mean by the
statement that you'd live the life of a
50-year-old by the time you were in your
20s yeah I believe what I meant in that
context is where I came from there's a
lot of rough individuals and I really
gravitated towards those rough
individuals on my own accord as a young
child there are some little rough
patches in the household but whose
household doesn't have those rough
patches but obviously it kind of leads
you down that path I started
skateboarding
um a very large majority of the people I
was spending time with started
purchasing and other things and and they
were where I'm from there was just a lot
of violence that was happening and I was
pulled into this world where you
especially the time period I grew up in
it's like you had to be a specific kind
of tough guy to to get through that
world and I was really born this artist
but really what that means for me is
seeing the world a particular from a
particular vantage point and it might
sound like a positive thing but where I
came from it made you a Target and so
you ended up being somebody that people
were after and not even in a bullying
context but just the groups of people
that I surrounded myself with were were
such negative characters I had no idea
where I was going a large majority of
people like grew up with unfortunately
I've passed from being from Cincinnati
Ohio you know there's a lot of things
have torn that place up
um but when I discovered film making it
led me into a place that I looked at all
these crazy episodes that I went through
some of which I'm writing into my take
on Romeo and Juliet right
now
um when I decided to start making movies
the things that felt negative to me that
hurt me emot
Al suddenly made sense it was as if the
universe put me in positions to
experience so many negative
episodes that I then was able to write I
then had something to say I had
something I experienced I had a group of
humans in the
country that I have experienced
similarities to and I knew the audience
of people I wanted to talk to so
unfortunately there was a lot of
craziness in my childhood growing up but
fortunately leaning into the filmic
world the film making route it um I
think it's only I've only benefited from
those experiences
but not sure if that answered anything I
hav even said any details
but do you feel looking back on it now
that um there was any memories that you
could take away you don't have to tell
me which ones by any means no I mean
there's nothing I'd want to take away
there's I mean I grew up in a group of
friends
where we got a lot of fist fights not
between each other just with a lot of
people around and I never wanted to
fight but I was always in this kind of
position to have to do
so
and I think that certain elements like
that you know and feeling the pain of
not wanting to come others harm and you
know and and then also they started
robbing people when I was 16 I came home
to my house well actually you know what
I think I was like 14 matter of fact I
think I might have been about 14 years
old I came home and the side door of the
house was broken in and all of my stuff
was gone and and and it was a group of
friends who pretended to be friends with
me suddenly came and you know did this
while I was at school so I mean that
that that's just one small episode in a
world of living you know in a small town
with nothing to do
perhaps uh but luckily again it fuels so
much with what you your scope is you
know and the kind of people you
understand and the kind of characters I
interacted with Warner Herzog always
says you know don't go to film school go
to life you know go out and just live
your life get arrested and and I like to
say that's what I did I followed War her
Zog so blame him no I'm just kidding I
want to ask more but I don't want you to
have to no you can ask me more I mean
whatever
um coming from a town maybe where film
making or being an artist or a writer
wasn't embraced MH what were some of the
things people said when you knew that
date the April 23rd 2006 that this is
what you wanted to do what were some of
the the statements if you were going to
make a movie with dialogue yeah and you
would just show their dialogue yeah yeah
what would the dialogue be on the screen
well well so when I was making films in
Ohio when I was bitten by the bug I was
then living in Cincinnati Ohio I'm
originally from Hamilton but then a
little way south of Cincinnati and when
I was in Cincinnati there'd be plenty of
individuals who wanted to make movies I
would spend time with because we were
friends and um their their take on it
was no one can make a feature film in
Cincinnati Ohio
because they couldn't do it they
couldn't step out and get it done so I
feel like every time I made another
movie there's always people saying you
know well there's no way to sell it
there's no way to get it out there
there's no way to make money off this it
can't be done and I think that's
happened I think that's said all over
the place I think everybody says that to
each other like for instance a friend of
mine who's 43 wants to go in and start
doing a music career and he wants to do
a music video for himself and people are
like you're 43 no one's going to but
really the truth is is that if he just
goes and does it there's no telling what
could happen there's no telling what can
come from it so there's always yeah that
there's tons of people you'll well you
know what one of my I was dating a girl
I must have been 24 25 at the time and I
had made a whole slew of shorts of this
point and we went to her father's house
for dinner and I showed him a short film
he watched it and and then he looked at
me and said don't quit your day job kid
and got up and walked away now this guy
was a country guy you know really and he
just he just looked at me don't quit
your day job he did no no emotion I he
he I I look at him during the short
there's nothing happening in his face I
thought this isn't for him and it was
one of the David Lynch ones one of the
early crazy strange David Lynch on so I
mean to his it wasn't a normal thing
that he would see on TV but um but those
are the moments that you just got to say
you know why are you living life anyways
you're living life for yourself so do
whatever makes you
happy do you think you know what you
would be doing if you were back in
Hamilton I I'd be making movies you'd be
making movies yeah in Cincinnati where I
was from where I I I I was making movies
out there and I was putting them in the
Esquire Theater the local art housee
movie theater right there and I could
have continued living that life you know
selling tickets making enough money to
to eat on and live um and then I just
decided to jump on a train and go out to
my sisters in San Francisco and see what
happens getting down to Hollywood and
you never know till you try to go out
and see what could take place so you
took the Train the am truck yes wow yeah
but that was cool three days and sitting
upright for all three days but it was an
adventure and there was a bunch of us in
there not people I knew but a lot of
Travelers
so
yeah